There's nothing like a great TV finale: one
conclusive episode which gives a show's characters
and stories - not to mention the viewers who've
faithfully followed along - a truly satisfying
send-off.
Unfortunately, however, there are plenty of
finales - often to really great shows - that
just can’t stick the landing.
From controversial conclusions to all-out
storytelling disasters, these episodes rank
among the most frustrating TV finales ever
made.
The Sopranos
A prestige HBO hit which heralded the dawn
of television’s golden age, The Sopranos
brought the medium to new heights, blurring
the long-standing lines between the small
screen and the large.
After six seasons - and countless twists and
turns - only one question remained to round
off the show: what would be the fate of Tony
Soprano?
The finale’s final scene is one of TV’s
most notorious: Tony, whilst out at dinner,
notices a man walk into the restaurant.
Is he just a fellow diner, or a hitman out
for blood?
Are any of the other patrons of the restaurant
out to get him?
The tension builds as his family arrives and
sits at the table one-by-one, but, just as
the scene appears to be moving towards a climax,
the screen abruptly cuts to black.
Tony's fate is left unresolved.
The Sopranos’ ending is jarring to say the
least, and, while many appreciate its subversive
brilliance, it's hard to not empathize with
anybody who doesn’t.
Dexter
Showtime’s flagship crime drama had already
fallen pretty far off the rails by the time
it came to an end.
At this point, the show had wandered into
a bizarre final storyline and managed to botch
the only good thread the show had left to
follow - Dexter's terrible secret being discovered.
Instead of any kind of definitive ending for
the character, Dexter fakes his own death
and escapes to Oregon, where he begins working
as a truck driver.
It was a bizarre, bitter, and inconclusive
letdown for the few remaining fans of a once-great
show.
Seinfeld
A precursor to some of today’s most popular
comedies about gangs of horrible people, Seinfeld
built its brand on an uncomfortable kind of
humor led by characters far more loathsome
than your typical protagonists.
In the process, it became one of television’s
most iconic and subversive shows.
The series finale, however, is notorious for
all the wrong reasons.
Seinfeld’s final episode found Elaine, Jerry,
George, and Kramer on trial for laughing at
a man who was being held at gunpoint.
During the trial, every person they've wronged
over the course of the series testifies against
them, putting into perspective just how odious
each character is.
By the end of the episode, they're all in
jail.
A popular series ending with a glorified clip
show was a highly unusual move, and the finale
was deeply divisive amongst fans.
Even Seinfeld himself admitted,
"I sometimes think we really shouldn't have
even done it."
“Very good, very good.
You know something?
No soup for you!
Come back, one year!
Next!"
How I Met Your Mother
Kind of spells it all out in the title, doesn't
it?
No matter how long the show ran, how many
detours it took or how many characters it
followed, it was always going to be the tale
of how Ted, the protagonist, met the mother
of his children.
As long as it answered that question in a
gripping and believable fashion, viewers were
going to be left happy.
Spoiler alert, though: they weren’t.
Rather than take the satisfying route, the
show’s writers decided to tack on a last-minute
stinger, explaining that the mother passed
away shortly before Ted started telling the
story to his kids, who insist that, the whole
time, he's actually been in love with his
friend Robin.
“No, this is a story of how you're totally
in love with Aunt Robin."
This was a romantic pairing the show had attempted
earlier, before Robin moved on and married
Neil Patrick Harris' character Barney.
To make matters worse, the show’s creators
actually filmed a happier ending, minus the
whole death thing, and for some reason decided
to go with this one instead.
It could have been so good.
True Blood
When the entire premise of your show revolves
around a single, major choice a character
has to make, you’d better make sure you
wrap things up in a satisfying manner.
To say True Blood failed to do this is an
understatement.
Anna Paquin's Sookie Stackhouse - the small-town
waitress who finds herself wrapped up in the
world of the supernatural - spends the whole
series trying to decide where her heart truly
lies.
Is it with Bill, the vampiric southern gentleman?
Or with Eric, the icy Nordic vampire lord?
Or maybe she'll end up with Alcide, the jacked
werewolf construction worker.
Sookie, as it turned out, ended up with none
of the above.
Alcide and Bill are both dead by the time
the show has come to an end, while Eric has
just moved on.
Instead, she ends up with... some human dude.
Viewers, predictably, weren’t happy.
Can you blame them?
Penny Dreadful
Penny Dreadful’s finale was, in many ways,
actually pretty great.
It wrapped up every character arc and convincingly
resolved most of the show’s plotlines - and
with such a large ensemble cast, it was no
easy task.
So why was this episode so frustrating?
Because nobody knew it was a finale.
Some controversy exists as to just why Penny
Dreadful ended when it did, but the important
thing to know here is that the show’s third
season was never marketed as its last.
It was only after the final shot had faded
out and the words “The End” appeared on
the screen that viewers realized they’d
just seen their last episode, ever.
For the show’s many die-hard fans and followers,
it was a painful and sudden demise - which,
considering the show in question, does seem
like a pretty apt way to end things.